[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de revista
de prensa aquí en directo américa y ya
este cómic en el estudio rosa pérez más
de borrosa bienvenida feliz mañana de
jueves arrancamos por supuesto esta
revista de prensa comentando el primer
año del presidente de eeuu joe biden en
distintos medios de comunicación rosa
buenos días raúl exactamente empezamos
si te parece por el país claro que sí y
rosa y titula los dos momentos que
marcaron el primer año de baile en la
casa blanca el artículo es antonia
laborde exacto 12 momentos como 12 meses
del año que lleva ya yo vaivén en la
casa blanca sin embargo nos podemos
comentar todos pero a destacar en primer
lugar que llegó pues al puesto de
presidente de eeuu en una sociedad más
dividida que nunca recuerda que tomó
posesión en una capital concretamente
militarizada y enfrente del capitolio
que había sido asaltado dos semanas
antes no de esta ceremonia en segundo
lugar destaca pues en la plan de rescate
económico para superar la crisis
económica desatada por la pandemia
en marzo de este 2021 como una victoria
que supuso en aquel momento y también el
acercamiento a europa y la vuelta a un
poco al multilateralismo
regresando a acuerdos como el de parís
no del clima pero también dan destaca
ciertos problemas como crítica a su
gestión migratoria y también que se haya
polarizado y politizado tanto no la
gestión de la pandemia por otro lado
también esa desastrosa es el adjetivo
calificativo que usan en este artículo
retirada de afganistán y así también
esta inflación récord a la que se está
enfrentando ahora mismo y por último las
divisiones en su propio partido que le
impiden también llevar adelante de
ciertos proyectos ejecutivos estos
puntos principales rosas que por
supuesto vamos a estar analizando a lo
largo de nuestro programa con nuestros
dos invitados del día pero seguimos con
revista de prensa vamos ahora con el
medio colombiano 'el espectador' donde
el periodista camilo gómez plantea
primer año de bailén porque el
presidente es tan impopular
rápidamente este periodista llega a la
conclusión con distintas fuentes de que
lo son básicamente problemas de
comunicación y como comentábamos
bloqueos en temas clave los que
responden al descontento no bloqueos
tanto por parte de la bancada
republicano como por ciertos miembros
demócratas y también asegura que pues la
situación parece que no es tan grave
sobre el terreno como muestran las
encuestas así es grosso y cerramos ya el
tema de bailén entonces con un artículo
en el en medio chino del 'global times'
by del año 1 decepciona el combatir hay
cobit 19 en parar una sociedad dividida
en arreglar la diplomacia y también en
relanzar la economía rosa exacto
destacar que la popularidad ahora mismo
del presidente esté por debajo del 50
por ciento aún así es más alta de lo que
era a estas alturas de mandato para
donald trump y básicamente haciendo la
comparación puede ser con el anterior
presidente estadounidense dice este
medio chino que la relación entre las
dos potencias es ligeramente mejor pero
que aún así joe biden ha decepcionado
intentando arreglando el panorama que
había dejado su predecesor ahora sí
aseguran sea tal y como apunta un poco
las previsiones los demócratas pierden
las elecciones legislativas de medio
término la relación entre eeuu y china
puede ser todavía más incierta y
compleja bueno rosa terminamos entonces
el tema de bailén como ya lo dijimos
vamos con un artículo de al yazira un
texto de opinión de michelle kwek dice
porque a sudáfrica debe cancelar la
nueva central de operaciones de la
multinacional amazon eso es hemos
seleccionado este artículo porque
precisamente estos días desde ayer hasta
el viernes es estado desarrollando en la
ciudad del cabo una audiencia que deberá
decidir si se bloquea la construcción de
un nuevo centro de operaciones en ciudad
del cabo lo que sucede es que pues haya
tanto poblaciones indígenas como
activistas medioambientales han llevado
el caso de esta central las de
operaciones del gigante tecnológico
amazon a los tribunales porque
consideran que estas tierras han central
ancestrales son un símbolo un símbolo de
la lucha
encuentra a los colonos europeos y por
otro lado también que esta construcción
dañaría en la biodiversidad y el medio
ambiente pero a esto también el
periodista añade que la llegada de
amazon a ciudad del cabo supondría pues
todavía profundizar más en lo que es el
colonialismo digital es decir que la
economía de la región se vea alterada
así como ha sucedido con la llegada de
amazon a otros lugares del mundo que
esto pues altera los derechos laborales
y también pues la economía de la
economía local vamos a ver ya de momento
amazon ha dicho que si finalmente se
bloquea esta construcción va a retirar
el proyecto rápidamente rosa cerramos
con perú dice el comercio la zona
afectada por el derrame de petróleo es
de un millón 739 mil metros cuadrados
exacto demos ha querido señalar este
reportaje fotográfico
de cómo están ahora mismo las costas de
perú afectadas por este derramamiento de
crudo aquí pueden entrar en el comercio
que está abriendo con este tema rosa
gracias entonces por la revista de
prensa del día de hoy nos vemos mañana
con más información por lo pronto nos
vamos ahora a saludar a nuestro primer
invitado el día para hablar justamente
lo que estábamos comentando el primer
año de joe vayan
[Música]